one of the many uh projects that i've
enjoyed been uh doing this this fall um
is voicing narrating the nfl films and
epics produced uh series nfl icons it's
a dynamite documentary soup to nuts on
the subject uh at hand and the subject
of this weekend's saturday night at 10
eastern time uh nfl icon show on epics
is joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line the goat from pro
football hall of fame san francisco
49ers and more
jerry rice back on the show how are you
jerry
rich i'm good have you watered have you
fertilized you know this this is an
excellent question jerry um normally i
don't flip it back on the person who
asked me the question but have you
watered have you fertilized today yes i
have and i'm i'm raring to go right now
because i'm on yours of course you're
you're jerry rice you water and
fertilize every day i mean that's the
way it works what's what's the best uh
uh speech you heard bill walsh give you
what was the best one where the whole
team's together and bill just either did
he just riled the you know rallied the
troops or what was you got a good one
for me
that was the one from uh the gladiator
russell crowe
that movie
so he just came in
uh he put the film on all the coaches
just walked out of the room
and we watched this clip saying
if you
whatever comes
into this arena if we work together
we have a chance of surviving we have a
chance of winning
and after watching that clip
rich
you had guys
ready to run through the wall
we were ready to play
and and i think we went out and uh we
won that super bowl
so that movie is the one that actually
got you up and running huh oh my oh my
god my heart was racing like crazy
and man because as a as a cohesive group
of guys
you have to work together
as one heartbeat
break the brick
you you can't be a weak link in that
chain if you a weak link in that chain
uh we're not going to have success on
the football field so you know
the majority of the guys they prided
themselves on how they practiced during
the week not being a weak leak in that
chain and i think that's the reason why
we were uh you know
had that down at sea for so long so uh
when was the first time jerry that you
met montana you got a good recollection
you're just drafted you're you're you're
coming out of
obviously small school hbcu and you're
drafted by the 49ers and and there's
montana
what was redwood city i'll never forget
it rich i'm sitting across and i'm
looking at
joe montana dwight clark ronnie lot all
of these you know hall of famers and i'm
saying to myself oh my god you know i'm
around legends right now and i'm just
this
small guy from mississippi hbcu
trying to find myself so you know it was
like during the headlights because i was
looking at greatness
and they had just won the super bowl i
think it was at stanford stadium against
the miami dolphins and i got drafted
right after that so just being around
those guys and and to watch those guys
how they conduct themselves
how to be a professional on and off the
football field you know it's just
something that i i try to uh follow so
did you have to
was there a moment where you felt you
had to prove yourself um or did they
know who you were did they see your your
your college tape at all or they just
had to trust the process that okay they
know who this kid um
from mississippi is
i mean what was that like jerry
hey rich i think they had to trust the
process because we didn't have that much
they didn't have that much film on me
but you know
they they they trusted bill walsh
and bill gave me the opportunity to live
a dream man because
you know to play professional football
and also get paid for it and i left i
never looked at it like it was a job it
was something that i just love doing
because you get the opportunity to
showcase your ability in front of 60 000
people or more going up against some of
some of the best competition ever
and you know i just i just wanted to
just prove to everyone that coming out
of mississippi valley state university
uh it's like almost like finding that
diamond in the rough
and
and and i just wanted to uh live up to
that expectation where they could you
know if i had success on the football
field then they can go back in there and
look at other players and hopefully give
them the same opportunity well what
jerry rice here in the rich eisen show
uh your your
your
work ethic is the stuff of legend right
i mean we we know about uh
many parts of your work ethic from
running hills and then obviously routes
and
where did that come from why essentially
two questions all rolled into one
rick i i think it came from my parents
because my father was a bricklayer and
my father would take me to work with him
during the during the summer
and it was very demanding work man we'll
get started about seven o'clock and the
temperature would be like maybe about
115 degrees outside
and
i
you know i had a job to do and i used to
be up on this scaffold that was about 20
feet in the air and i remember my
brother
uh
throwing bricks up to me
the bricks would separate in the air i
would snatch them out of the air
and you know it just taught me about
hard work and dedication but you know he
was he was like the provider of the
family
and i just knew
that i wanted to do something special in
life i wanted to
uh
if i could
you know play professional football
build my parents uh a house in
starkville mississippi that was the
first thing the second i signed my
contract
you know um you know i wanted to build
my parents a new home and i was able to
do that but
you know i i think it the hard work just
came from my parents and uh and it was
just dedication was there ever a moment
where you you you did just say you know
what i'm tired i i don't need to
i can just rest on my laurels i'm i'm
i'm already done this been done that i
mean did you that never creeped in your
mind never not even once
never never never got complacent stayed
hungry
uh
my teammates would tell me every day
like why are you working so hard i just
felt like every time i stepped onto that
football field i had to prove myself i
had to earn it you know if i had if i
was going into year eight
i still felt i had to go to training
camp and i had to show everybody that i
deserved to be that starter uh on that
given sunday monday those playoff games
or those super bowls
so i never got complacent
jerry rice here on the rich eisen show
nfl icons jerry rice's story on epics uh
saturday night at 10 eastern time nfl
films
and and uh your your story what what
what what would you say your story is
jerry what is your story
i think my story is that uh
just hard work
the appreciation
uh
fans inspired me to go out and play my
best football
uh
the fear of failure that just continued
to push me
never felt like i was one of the
greatest of all time
and just continue to work hard so when i
think when people think about me they
think about my legacy of work ethic
that's it
that is that is a that is a fact
um
so uh what do you make uh jerry rice
here on the rich eisen show uh what do
you make of the current 49ers team jerry
what are your two cents on that one i
think they're still searching for an
identity
they're two and four right now
and somewhere that the players got to
take over the team and that was
something bill walsh always did he would
let the players take over the team you
know how you practice you know if things
are not going right
doing a ball game or something like that
having those veterans to step up pull
uh the team together together
rally you know say what you have to say
and say hey look
we got to go out there on that football
field we got to win that this football
game
so i think they're still searching right
now i'm hoping that they really get hot
in november
and uh and
when you two and four what i don't want
to see
is players quitting
no matter what you know because you you
paid
uh to do a job
you have to take pride in it even if the
season is not going the way you want it
to go you still have to go out there and
you have to continue to want to get
better so i don't want to see that
aspect of the game but you know
hopefully they can get really hot in
november and somehow get into the
playoffs what do you mean by walsh would
let the players take over what do you
mean by that well but the coaches they
can they can put together a game plan
right but the players they they got to
have you know that work ethic they got
to set the standard and
if a veteran is seeing like a younger
guy not doing what he's supposed to do
pull that young guy
aside have a conversation with him let
him know that hey we have a certain
standard here and uh and right now
you're not living up to that standard
so that's really what bill wanted uh you
know the players to uh
uh pretty much do so maybe there's not
enough of those guys on this current
roster i mean because kyle shanahan he's
smart enough to know um you know what
what is up or what needs to be retooled
or fixed so like
what what what counsel would you give
him on that front of something that you
saw that walsh was able to
fine-tune
jerry well i think what california and
he got to uh decide if uh we're going to
be a running team or if we're going to
be a passing dean
and you got to stick with it
and uh you know i understand that you
know george kittle is hurt right now and
jimmy g is not playing his best football
but put those players in a position to
be successful in the football field now
those players got to they they they got
to go out there and do the job
they got to be accountable
and they got to get it done but you know
decide on one if because bill was always
that type of coach he felt like if we
ran the football it opened up the pass
and we threw the ball that opened up the
run so you got to you know pick one of
the other
and and and i understand mostly went
down but i still believe they have
running backs that can step in because
it's always about rich
next man up
do you want to have injuries in football
do you have any do you have any two
cents on what might be up with ayuk i
mean kidd was you know taken off last
year and right now he's just
he's gone i mean he's just
i mean his production is virtually
non-existent
yeah you know
i think we all go through uh
different scenarios and stuff like that
and you got to be able to fight through
it and you got to have veterans around
you that that that can pull you aside
and have that conversation with you so
maybe that's it right now i i feel like
he's very talented uh but it's all about
the design and you know maybe uh get
this guy more opportunities i don't know
but
right now
you know i would say with the san
francisco 49ers yes sir their backs are
against the walls
i want to see how they're going to come
out
and and like i stated earlier i don't
want to see no quit in this team i i
still want to see the effort and and and
this team trying to go out there and win
football games and if they can get hot
in november uh you know
then we'll see what happens all right
then last one for you on the current
state then jerry i mean this
i i don't think this is even in the same
area code of it but i'll bring it up
anyway i mean you were there had a front
row seat from you know when steve young
showed up and montana was there and
obviously jimmy g doesn't have the
resume of montana and trey lance is a
kid who's you know hardly done anything
in this league well you know young came
from um from from the uh usfl i get it
do you think there's anything up with
the quarterback
position and the fact that it was jimmy
g to start and now lance is there or
anything that could be kind of
getting this team off a kilter because
there's two quarterbacks sitting right
there with the elephant in the room with
the kid who just got drafted at all well
you know rich i've never i've never been
one of those guys that felt like you
could
uh
you know have two quarterbacks
i always wanted to know exactly who was
on the center
and and whatever i had to do try to and
uh to make that
that person on the center great on the
football field so you you need those
reps uh you need that chemistry and all
those things
you know and and i think with uh kyle
shanahan you know he was saying jimmy g
was gonna play then trey lance was gonna
play and i just don't i you know
i i don't like that mixture
but you know
kyle shanahan is uh
he's the coach of uh the san francisco
49ers uh he makes all of those uh
decisions but
i was one of those guys that always felt
like i needed to know who was gonna be
that guy
and then i was gonna taper my game
around him where he was going to be
successful on the football field
how's goat fuel how's everything going
on in your businesses hey man the
greatest of all time and it's doing well
you know i'm excited
we got a lot of goats out there and uh
you know i'm very fortunate to have my
daughter as my ceo
and we are scaling and we're building
we're having a great time but the
greatest of all time is not just for
athletes it could be a frontline worker
hey rich you know you you're a goat
right
well you've seen it firsthand jerry
you've seen it firsthand the it being
speed you've seen it you've seen it
firsthand twice now jack
that's why you the greatest of all time
jerry your
your large ass and your philanthropy and
your help with my run last two years has
really taken it to new heights and um i
can't thank you enough for that man and
anytime you're there it just sends a
complete jolt through anybody
that's part of the fundraising effort so
you are the man i just wanted to say
that out loud one more time really hey
rich i'm always going to be there for
you man and
fantastic work that you're doing for
saint jude thank you right back at you
uh jerry you take care uh appreciate the
call you'd be well all right that's
jerry rice check out nfl icons with uh
jerry rice's story great story
one that's been told many times but not
like this
through nfl films in epics 10 eastern
time on
saturday night
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here